hey guys Pete peppers here and going to
make a short video today about the
lollipop hammers in candy crush jelly
saga some of these we're familiar with
from the other candy crush games the
original lollipop hammer here was in
candy crush the original game and we
have a striped which is also in candy
crush soda saga and then we have two new
ones that are in jelly and one is the
color bomb hammer and the wrapped candy
hammer so we're going to talk about what
each one of these does I purchased a
couple of them so that I can explain
different things you can do with them
and I'll just talk in general about you
know most people don't like to to buy
boosts that a lot of people do and so if
you really come into a tough situation
where you need one this will at least
give you an idea of what you need to
think about whenever you're going to use
one so all lollipop hammers and candy
crush jelly are based off the original
and this is a simple but effective tool
that will basically take out anything on
the board when I say take out I mean you
know it'll hit it so like here we have a
multi-layered blocker if we hit this it
won't remove the blocker it will take a
layer off just like if we hit it with a
match or with a fish so you know we
could hit this we could hit this this
lifts licorice trap here and it would
remove it the fish would still be there
or wouldn't set the fish off we could
hit this orange candy it would take a
candy out and it would drop these red
down and make them you know cascade into
a match we could hit this ball of fish
here and it would take one layer of the
licorice off the outside so it's simple
its it would come in handy
in a situation where you need to save a
move but make something happen so like
when we use a hammer you can see we have
30 30 moves left right now it won't take
one of those away so that's really where
it comes in most handy is towards the
end whenever you you're just about to
finish and you can't because you're
going to run out of moves so go ahead
and make that match there so let's say
this fish we're trying to spread jelly
in this particular level so say you know
we want to set up this fish maybe
there's one square that needs covered
but we only have one you know we don't
have a way to match it we can just
activate the hammer by clicking on it
you see there's a a glow that sets off
position over the fish and it'll hit it
and set it off so pretty simple and like
I said you know it'll hit all these
other things the blockers and things
like that so you know one more example I
guess hit this red one and that will
make this that will make this green
match whatever that candy's removed
so whenever you're using that you know
I'm sure there'll be a put a way that we
can earn some of these things later once
they start to have many games like soda
does and original does so these are also
the least expensive but you know they're
pretty limited and what they actually do
compared to the other ones so the
striped Ollie pop hammer is basically a
combination of the original hammer and
the striped candy so we click on it and
the same thing happens we get this this
glowing effect and so now whenever we
hit this yellow candy it'll hit the
candy and remove it but it'll also send
off a you know striped in both
directions so let's see how that looks
so you see that's a lot more powerful it
took off the licorice up here it took
off the layer of that and it also spread
the jelly for us in both directions
until it hit the licorice here so that's
definitely a cool one
if you're you know if you're trying to
think about what it's going to do like I
said just think about the original one
is is the hammer just just hits a square
so when you think of you know think of
the stripe to add a striped to that
threat you know to that equation you
know it's going to go in both directions
the color bomb hammer is the same basic
concept it builds off the original but
with a color bomb so here if we hit say
well let's let's look at it from outside
if it's not a jelly level or four on a
jelly level we hit this blue one right
here it's going to remove all the dark
blue candies from the board that can be
helpful in a lot of different situations
just like a color bomb is helpful but
also on on on a jelly board if we hit
one that's on the jelly when it spreads
it's going to spread the jelly to all
it's going to remove all these screens
but it's also going to spread the jelly
and in this case it's going to remove
this one and it's going to make this
fish for us so we're going to go ahead
and hit the green and we see how that
sets off a lot of different things
happen at once so that one is I would
say one of the most powerful over all
I'm gonna set off this fish ball real
quick
and then I'm going to get this one down
to one just so that you know here if we
use the stripes this doesn't have a
color so you know if we use the striped
on this one it's going to open this up
and send it off I don't know we can't
actually do that I wonder if we can hit
it with this no so you can't hit the
balls of fish just learn that right now
so the last lollipop hammer is the
wrapped lollipop hammer and it's the
same thing not very complicated if it's
a it's a regular hammer but this will
actually clear off a larger area alright
so what I'm going to do with this one is
I'm going to hit this blocker in the
middle and let's just look at it what it
does here so you see it took out all of
the all of the stuff in that 3x3 square
so I hope this video helps you
understand how they work and you know
like I said if you're in a jam it's it's
important to know which ones would be
best for whatever situation you have you
get a couple free when you first start
out so try to save those for you know
the right time because you do have to
buy them after and like I said it's been
a trend in all the King games lately it
add minigames to where you can earn earn
things like this so I'm assuming in the
next couple months we'll see that come
down the road we'll see some kind of
game like the Bubblegum Hill or you know
some of the ones that are in the other
games you know - so you'll be able to
earn these so it's good to know how they
work and it's good to know when to use
them if you have any questions about it
let me know in the comments I'll
especially be watching the comments
right in the beginning so I'll try to
answer them all and let me know what you
think I think this it's safe to say as
far as the way the things are laid out
and everything now this might be what as
far as we go and then we'll get some
more boosters probably that we can
activate beforehand like we do in the
they're two candy crush's like you know
where you can activate a color bomb or
color candy or whatever so let me know
what you think if they're good if
they're worth the money whatever
whatever is on your mind and please like
the video to show some support to the
channel and subscribe to get access to
all my latest level videos for the games
I play and all these how-to and help
videos that I make my channel is the
only one that does that right now and
I'd appreciate your support so I'll talk
to you soon thanks